[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, hi, y'all,
and welcome to Todd Taft's
Odd Crafts Podcast.
[ Light laughter ]
I'm Todd Taft.
Now, on this show, we take a
look at
the weird and wonderful world
of D-I-Y knickknacks
that you can T-R-Y at home.
[ Laughter ]
Today, we're joined by one of my
favorite crafters,
but it's his first time on the
show and he's a little nervous.
So please join me
in giving a warm welcome
to Carole St. James.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi, Carole.
-Hi.
-Hi, Todd.
-Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-Oh, I'm sorry, Todd.
I'd shake your hand,
but my hands are just
covered in Mod Podge.
-Oh, I've been there, Carole.
What do you have for us today?
-Well, my first one -- and this
is really special to me, Todd.
-Huh.
-This is a little pet sheep.
-Well, look at that.
-And all you need to make these
are toothpicks, a cotton ball,
and the secret ingredient.
[ Laughter ]
-Secret ingredient, what's that,
imagination?
[ Light Laughter ]
-Those little googly eyes.
-Ah. That's precious.
Does it have a --
does it have a name?
-Well, that's the great thing
about these, Todd.
You can name them whatever you
want, because they're yours.
But this one is named Diablo.
[ Laughter ]
Because he is trouble.
-He -- he looks like a rascal
that just wants to
stay up all night.
[ LAUGHTER ]
He -- he looks like he wouldn't
wear his seatbelt in the car.
-No, no. Not Diablo.
-No, you won't be
counting him before bed.
-No. Well, let me put this
little guy away
before my heart just melts.
-Oh, wow.
I love this sheep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, Carole, how -- how did you
come up with your next item?
-Well, my next item,
when I was young --
this is a great story, Todd.
-Yeah.
-When I was young,
my dad sat me down
and he gave me
a can and some yarn.
And he said,
"Boy, go make something."
-Wow.
-So I came up with this.
-Mm-hmm.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Now -- now, what do --
what do you call that?
-Well, I'll give you a hint.
-Okay.
-I was in
"The Devil Wears Prada."
[ LAUGHTER ]
-Anne Hathaway?
-Close.
Can Hathaway.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Can Hathaway.
-Hey, that actually reminds me,
I actually cooked something up
after the new year.
And I think it's pretty crafty.
-I can't wait to see.
-Oh, well,
you're about to see it.
I'm gonna see it as well.
These are my fun glasses.
[ Laughter ]
-Hello.
Fashion police.
No crime here.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, well...
-They're pretty easy to make.
I just bedazzled
a leftover pair of glasses
from New Year's Eve, 2008.
[ Light laughter ]
-I just love
that they're vintage.
Hold on.
Let me take a mental picture.
[ Laughter ]
Let me take another one.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Where are these going?
-I am posting those
on my brain Pinterest.
[ Laughter ]
-You can actually have
your own pair,
'cause I made two of these.
[ Light laughter ]
-Oh, mylanta
-Try those on.
[ Light laughter ]
-[ Singing ] I can see clearly
now that my glasses are on
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stop it.
You're too much.
I don't want my neighbor
complaining.
[ Light laughter ]
Well, it looks like we're down
to our last craft.
-Oh, what is it?
-Well, here's a hint.
It's cute.
It's got fruit.
And it's perfect
for your tiny commute.
-I give up.
-Look at that.
-I don't know what --
I didn't know how I was gonna
make that.
[ Laughter ]
Ta-da!
Now don't be fooled because this
thing goes "berry" fast.
[ Laughter ]
I actually -- I actually drank a
5-hour energy
right before the show.
[ Light laughter ]
-Well, I could just tell you
were on something.
-You could, yeah.
-I could.
I could tell you were
on something.
-If it lasts longer
than five hours,
I have to call a doctor.
-Well, I'll tell you what, that
little car just took a DNA test.
-Uh-huh.
-And it came back that it is
100% that kitsch.
[ Laughter ]
-You want it?
-Are you saying what
I think you're saying?
-Together: Craft swap!
[ Laughter ]
-Here you go.
-You want that--
Oh!
Actually --
Actually I like it --
You think maybe Diablo
can ride this?
-No, stop it.
-Look at that.
That's what -- that's what
teamwork is right there.
There he goes.
Look at him there.
-Wait a minute.
-Diablo's not wearing
a seatbelt.
Someone call Nine-Fun-Fun.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's Diablo's world,
we're just living in it.
That's all the time we have for
today's podcast.
My thanks to Carole St. James.
Carole, would you like
to join me --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Would you like to join me in
singing out to break?
-Does a raisin get an --
[ Laughs ]
Does a raisin get an invite
to a wrinkle convention?
-Here we go.
One, two, three, four.
[ Together ]
♪ Making little treasures ♪
♪ Out of little bits of trash ♪
♪ It's Todd Taft's
Odd Crafts... Podcast ♪
-Thank you so much, Carole.
It's a pleasure.
I know you have Mod Podge all
over you, but this was great.
Look at Diablo.
Diablo, he's a little rebel.
He isn't wearing a seatbelt.
[ Cheers and applause ]